I won't take a little roll here Jay
Quellin here you are present but lucky I
hear uh-huh d nice here good just Seco
Thank You mr. Garvey
what is ay-ay-ron some of us need to
leave a few minutes early today oh is
that so mm-hmm and what pray tell is the
reason for this premature Exodus your
book photos um we have to leave 15
minutes early to meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers but I
taught him in the city for over 20 years
now y'all want to leave my class early
it's y'all can go meet up at the club
[Music]
ridiculous mr. Garvey ah son of a bitch
did ask cutter just then yes I'm gonna
throw you a goddamn window what Jay
Quellin mr. Garvey we're telling the
truth week we have clubs at this school
we have clubs for special interests okay
I see so y'all wanna play yeah okay
we're gonna play little games huh
I'll play I'm more than happy to play
some games with y'all anyone who's in a
club stand yo ass up uh-huh oh yeah that
is that is the usual suspects what the
hell club are you in Jay Quellin Future
Leaders of America okay okay
how would you know if you're gonna be a
leader in the future is there a Stargate
and no bedroom can you travel through
time jay-kwelin no this sit the flip
now but like a here's the thing I don't
even know why I'm about to ask you this
but like a what club are you in part of
the spanish club spit this you about as
Spanish as Rhian Seacrest which a
big-ass fraggle rock hair how about you
D nice I'm in the Chess Club I'm sorry
sweetheart you are not in the mosquito
bite Club maybe it's hurtful truthful
areas hey Ron hey what club are you in
I'm the president of the glee club why
did I talk dedicated to a TV shut tight
yo ass - oh-shag-hennesy Sophos right
now before I bust the club up in your
butt no miss Thomas and deceitful cheeky
nurus and deplorable
this is principal o'shaughnessy students
please report to the gymnasium for your
club photos fake announcement now does
anybody in here have a valid reason but
leaving this classroom Timothy I gotta
go pick up my daughter you're excused
[Music]